hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to seven days to die
the survival hoard crafting game this is
one that weighed actually recommended to
me because he has been playing it over
on his channel and I was very interested
in what it was but I found out that the
game is in early alpha however buying
the game now cost 35 bucks so it'll have
to be pretty incredible for me to
recommend it nah my eager to give it a
try but it has to be something pretty
darn special
so let's get to it I'm gonna play it I
think he was supposed to be played
multiplayer but I'm just gonna go out of
my own 24 hours cycle is 30 minutes that
sounds good to me gives me a day night
day night yeah yeah that'll work
okay game Oh survival game world news
this game game Mar mark Blair's dump
there we go got that it's a private game
it's only gonna be me and mine getting
passwords it's good no one look out my
password and she motors off I guess
let's do this I'm ready it is an online
enabled game by the way
but once again in early alpha I think
it's just add a kick started too so it
is trying to support itself and I know
it's hard but 35 bucks oh boy alright
press the Oh press ENTER it's joinable
okay alright so the main thing or right
off the bat today you need to know is
that at least when I saw a way playing
is that BAM boom tree punching still in
effect because it's about oh wait what
no I see it okay there's Christ
I train every day to become the better
oh I gotta collect them all individually
okay so anyway what what the idea is
that it's a it's a crafting survival
game so if you thinkin minecraft you win
the prize cuz that's kind of what it is
but whoa oh yeah as a gizmo and a dude
daddy are those cupcakes oh they're
candy tin cans candy tin can and a gun
well hot diggity excuse me can you come
back here alright
no wait how do I wait I just oh did I
mention there are zombies in it cuz
there are zombies in it okay I gotta
punch it from the base of it or else
it's not gonna crack right and not all
its gonna go down you think this would
hurt my fist but I am trained under the
greatest martial artist for years at a
time
I really wish this would just Auto
collected as they go over now I don't
know much about this game I didn't watch
Wade's video enough to get a good feel
of what it was for all I know is that
I'm supposed to get or I'm supposed to
build a shelter ISM as fast as possible
other than that I don't really know and
since a 30 may 30 made a 30-day 30
minute night cycle I can't for the life
of me why do I even try
can I just say that's oddly satisfying
now this isn't to be confused with
another game that's still being
developed that is also gonna be what
whoa what the hell's that I know it's a
pig now but oh my god oh it's lovely
it's actually is very minecraft s with
biomes and kind of squared off areas
excuse me Hart what the hell is that
sound you know for those of you who have
played minecraft like whoa like back
when you first started playing I guess I
can't pick up dirt what possible use
could I have with you in this round
piggy okay so um excuse me I hear
whispering I don't know you were almost
dead I could've eaten your goop not your
goop your giblets that's what I meant
okay I am hearing whispering that is
telling me to kill all humans that is
not healthy I know what is sane and I am
NOT or I am don't call me on that I need
to get to I saw I thought I saw some
buildings in the distance this is like
this seriously is like the first time
then I played Minecraft and I had no
idea what to do so I what is that what
oh that's a garbage don't punch the
garbage see I don't have like oh those
are buildings
could you not I here's oh there are
zombies in the city of course I should
have known I don't even know how to
build I'm actually quite perturbed I
feel you know suddenly I feel very alone
and wish I was playing this with someone
else right now I'll take some scrap
metal I hate to keep drawing parallels
to Minecraft but that was exactly how I
felt the first time I played and nights
gonna come any any any moment and I'm
going to be on the middle of nowhere
maybe maybe all I do is like just I
literally just flop I think this is what
I what I do i excuse me what what what
is that what is that I don't know if I
can make like a crafting table or
something this does not feel right I'm
building it oh my oh my oh wow oh wow
I'm building like a legit it's forming
into a wall that's so cool here zombie I
hear lots of zombies what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna try to oh don't tell me to
kill all humans cuz I probably won't
probably maybe definitely will I'll use
my youtube fame for evil
was that sound effect really necessary I
don't know how to craft sir likens I
don't want to suicide no it was an
option they said to suicide
how do i what buttons do I help me swim
adduce wha-what oh there's the map is
the inventory Oh logcat log cabin wood
oh oh oh oh beautiful beautiful oh I can
finally do something and I I don't know
what I don't know what this means
what hell yeah I can do stuff I don't
know what what I'm going to figure it
out soon I can turn that into oh is
there no candy in there oh okay alright
I'm banging on all cylinders now I make
an iron ignant oh oh cool that's so cool
wait hang on how do I make porgy metal
okay now I'm getting it now I'm banging
on all cylinders I don't know oh I get
it
there we go okay forging metal then make
that oh that's so cool I mean it's not
anything revolutionary but it's crafting
rusty metal door I will take a rusty
metal door for my cabin that I am going
to make that will prevent me from being
eaten with my brains all over the ground
thank you good night I'm gonna just
abandon that and I'm gonna make a cabin
and nothing can this this this is a
little an Anita I guess I need to punch
the grassed out of here oh sweet how do
i nom those delicious oh so good oh oh
it was better even better than the first
Oh
Oh I keep forgetting that I actually
have to press e to collect stuff
punching grass everything festering
corpses festering corpse
I hear that whispering again telling me
once again to kill all humans but for
now I won't listen to it for now just
just for now god damn it this grass is
tough hard to punch Jesus the first bits
of grass that went down easy
oh maybe it's cuz I'm out of stamina
that would make a lot of judo game blech
blech blech yeah collect deflected get
it get it get it get it get it hurry
hurry hurry we're running out of
daylight here feeling very pressed for
time and I keep thinking that I hear
zombies right behind me which they
probably are okay we're gonna do a nice
block the area here gonna build us up a
log cam and it's gonna be beautiful
gonna be gorgeous this is building very
strangely but I'm not gonna question it
too much oh it's gonna be beautiful
beautiful and the door is gonna go right
rusty metal door is gonna go right god
dammit
wish though is easier if the person I
have to press
oh I see that rotated okay so can you
please know you do there there we go
yeah baby oh yeah I've never been in so
excite of a door maybe I didn't need to
punch the grass oh yeah I didn't need to
find grass well I wasted a lot of time
but then again if that isn't the story
of my life just wasting time non-stop I
wish out you know I kind of wish the
hologram lake the holographic image of
the block you're potentially gonna place
wasn't actually there because it's
actually just a little bit distracting
all right one more layer up this is this
is Amba minecraft this zombie craft what
the hell
I'll happen to that one okay they were
coming out rather Square and regular and
then all of sudden they decided to take
a rather stupid turn oh oh
once I have this home base I'm actually
gonna go out
padhu ski the Bam Bam Bam I hear you
thump them do not think that I do not as
I do
I don't even know if I need to build a
roof I build anything hay bale hay bale
don't know why I need it once again but
I have it did I just drop all my [ __ ]
okay there we go got it
stop Kelly made a kill it happens every
time I look out at that that place it's
my home
it looks fantastic I'm a genius
and I'm gonna try to venture out for
supplies while it's still daytime come
at me bro
come at me
wanna play play [ __ ] way want a
flip-flop and play no come on step
closer don't cross that line
okay don't cross that line well that
didn't kill you I thought that was gonna
hold oh oh there we go
yes I'm the Grove hi oh they're all
looking at me funny gosh some to stay
come on come on
I don't think I want this can of ham is
this can of ham like the new can of
beans okay this is gonna be really hard
to survive this night I'm just guessing
oh no oh no I am out of bullets and I
punch them yeah Wow
guess I really didn't need to waste my
bullets boom don't have no ham you look
like you have some ham lady lady I
really don't want your ham
lady please don't give me your hand okay
will you fall over and die please please
please can you [ __ ] just fall over
and die already
you know what screw this this isn't
working out I'm just gonna go around you
take this stuff from this big what he
disappeared he vanished
he did done disappear why why why did he
vanish
oh good oh this is perfect why did I
even bother just take all yes again I'm
getting a little too excited about I'm
gonna take those hubcaps you give them
to me Oh nurse love that shotgun sweet
there's all kinds of stuff I didn't even
need to do nothing that's it dear
I'm gonna shoot that deer in the face
I'm gonna shoot that deer in the frickin
face it sounds like they're much closer
than they actually are I'm gonna eat
good tonight sorry Peter whoa
and not PETA from The Hunger Games
Wow three femur I can adapt three femurs
Oh son don't go down on me go down on me
son that would sound awkward out of
context
don't anybody quote me on that one what
keeps exploding
I do not know was that that the only
curse is that captain squeaker oinker
seemed a little startled
let me alleviate you sorry I'm not sorry
sorry not very oh he looks so sad oh
well just another further machine for
pigs
it is getting dark all of this I don't
even know if my cabin is gonna keep me
alive let alone protect me from the zom
zoms oh that pig died oh my okay let's
see if I can crap anything plant fibers
what do I do with that
can I eat can of ham I don't have a can
opener so I don't know if I can I don't
know if I can't open that can of hand
and the hand and him awning hey I love
an awning do I do it how do I make an
awning how do I make an awning what what
materials you say that I have stuff here
but you don't wood okay how do I make an
awning Oh
nude Walker eliminated bloated Walker
sounds like someone's having a real good
time in there anyway
um I'm gonna try to learn more about
this before I play it a second time I'm
gonna just do like I just finished a the
decay
I'm just gonna do a couple episodes of
this just to give it a feel to really
get into the game but it's interesting
so far I'm still confused need a guide I
need a tutorial so anyway good thank you
all so much for watching click the
entity that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
why there are so many